prepare for the all-new sequel to the
franchise reboot based on the sequel to
the original franchise star trek into
darkness did someone forget a : get
ready for the sequel that JJ Abrams
swore would be different from Star Trek
to the Wrath of Khan except for this
part the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of a few and this and of course
that but JJ's not just stealing from the
wrath of God he's recycling everything
you loved about his last hour Trek movie
- right Kirk betting aliens spot
throwing tantrums Kirk and pike breaking
red bull's face jumping hallway running
old Spock and Reuben more lens flares
hey you guys get the point so bride once
again with james t kirk the galaxy's
worst Starfleet captain as he desecrates
a cultures gods attack I no idea but
they were powered to it let's experience
crew members go out of spite do you make
my resignation or not I do promotes
inexperienced crew members out of
convenience
the new chief I kicked him and fails to
protect his group and the enterprise and
downtown San Francisco
cringe at the stereotypical treatment of
the two female leads hora an otherwise
competent officer who stops a
life-or-death mission to nag her
boyfriend for not sharing his feelings
you prefer not to discuss are you really
gonna do this right now
what never seems to reply you're under
my firm's I'm sorry captain just two
seconds and newcomer Carol Marcus who's
only there for one reason
make that two reasons
watches this crew faces their most
dangerous enemy yet Kai he's a ruthless
villain shall we begin
so diabolical he'll not kill Spock let
Kirk express his feelings and ultimately
be completely justified in his actions
my crew is my family is there anything
you would not do for your family got a
min he's got a point so boldly go to a
ridiculous alternate Star Trek timeline
where the enterprise survives more hits
than it took in the entire original
series magical interplanetary
transporters make starships obsolete
death has been cured by magical super
blood my synthesize the serum from his
super blood and whenever they're in a
Space Jam old Spock is just a face time
away mr. Spock
mr. Spock uh I can just picture the next
Star Trek already Peter did it did it
Klingon general Chang the Horta fully
ins the Borg all really bad anybody else
we should look out for
we covered the Gorn right yes it is just
a test do not actually kill the goal
correct oh and when you go back to 1930s
New York you have to kill Kirk's
girlfriend or Hitler will win World War
two fascinating oh and be sure to track
down a couple hop back whales because
that'll save you a lot of time later on
humpback whales well that should cover
it now I believe you have something for
me oh you lucky dog best I could get was
that weird fan dance and Star Trek 5 are
we sure this is not going to rip apart
some time space continuum
you want my help or not starry captain
twerk smock old smock Margaret Jo Carlos
Santana a doctor not a miracle worker
bling ons Scott the engineer Robocop
thumbnail and eggs benedict cummerbund
star trek into darkness are we sure we
don't want to put a colon in there
thanks for watching
set youtube to subscribe big thanks to
how it should have ended you guys Rock
check them out a year ever wanted to see
what this buttery voice looks like or
who makes the honest trailers click here
to see the making of this honest trailer
welcome to good burger home of the good
burger can I take your order
I'm a pretty pretty princess kick his
ass seabass tread lightly